welcome everybody happy weekend I wanted
to make a quick video because a lot of
you are asking about my wall you see it
in in my live recordings and who the
people are and what the meaning is so I
thought I would make this quick video
for the weekend few guys to learn about
the wall and to get some inspiration for
what you might go to create in your
office so first up we've got steve jobs
here and there's a picture of me and
nina and hayden now this is where my
computer is and normally i put the
picture of Nina and hayden here because
i can look at it and then you know i can
see them here but when i do the live
recordings i'm over here so that people
can see me in and hayden as well so jobs
is number one and that you know his
thing of just wanted to make an impact
and make a dent in the universe that's a
constant reminder that i have in my head
when I walk in and I see this picture
next behind me is Howard Schultz and he
is the head of starbucks and the thing
about starbucks that i love and how were
chilled specifically is about leading
through values and is one great clip
that we featured on the channel before
where there was a guy who got up at a
starbucks shareholders meeting and was
upset that starbucks was recognizing gay
marriage he felt that gay marriage is
wrong and said what should not recognize
gay marriage and then would hurt the
starbucks price and Howard Schultz got
up on stage and said this is not an
economic decision we're doing this
because it's the right thing to do and
because it aligns with our values and I
really love that sentiment and ever
since I've been that Howard Schultz fan
and picked up his books and so that's
why he's here is to you know make an
impact but make the impact to values
next up
this is a this is a picture of me with
my parents I feel like I'm around havens
each year six or seven and the reason
why this is on the wall is because my
parents were the foundation of belief
for me I've told you guys in tons of
videos at the the believe here right
there on the shirt comes from my mom's
last name is mr. Lee my dad was I
Salinas Carmichael they would always
tell me I mcus truly Carmichael and I
can do anything that I wanted to put my
mind to and I remember always have to
sit down a report card season and I
would never get his good grades as my
sisters and they would tell me that and
that was just filming with confidence
and every time that I talk to do
something different or new you know even
if they didn't have any knowledge or
experience like when I wanted to try to
learn about baseball cards and self
baseball cards you know they had no
interest in baseball cards but they
always made me believe in myself so here
I was this 12 year old kid negotiating
with 40 rolls and 50 rolls over baseball
cards and they would drive me to
baseball card shows and take me to
spring training every year in Florida to
meet the players and get autographs and
so this is a theme and the store that
there's a reason to be ordered here too
so jobs is have an impact Howard Schultz
is doing through values and my golly was
believed that came from my parents why
falling here hits something next up is
AP Giannini here we go he's the founder
bank of america is my favorite
entrepreneur may be thinking why is a
banker favorite entrepreneur for me he
was the belief banker he was at a bank
and he was having success as a board
member of a bank after being successful
entrepreneur and he wanted the bank to
expand to offer loans to immigrants and
hard-working you know blue-collar type
of workers where he was an immigrant
himself and at the moment banks only
lent to really safe deals really save
businesses and didn't want to lend money
to immigrants because was too much of a
risk where he then decided to quit that
bang leave the board of directors and
open up his own bank across the street
from the original bank that he was on
the board of and he lent money to
immigrants he made loan
decisions based off of a handshake the
calluses on somebody's hand and a look
in their eye can you imagine a banker
today making a loan to somebody based on
a look in their eye sounds crazy right
but that's a foundation of Bank of
America I don't know how much bank of
america kind of still rings true to his
initial visions but I love him and for
me it's the application of believe so my
parents taught me to believe this is the
application of belief and he bet on Walt
Disney when nobody would give him money
like Walt Disney wanted to make
full-length animated videos which
everybody thought was crazy but he gave
him the money to do it he been on the
Golden State bridge when everybody
thought it was crazy and they shouldn't
do it so he had a history of just biting
a little guy believing in them and I
really respect that and that's why I'm
banker is my favorite entrepreneur an in
last up is the most controversial mr.
Kanye West and I talked about him a lot
on the various episodes that I've had
for me I feel like a lot of people don't
give Kanye enough respect for the stuff
that he's done and you can learn from
him even if you don't want to be exactly
like him you know if you don't respect
the fact that he might you know
interrupt people and say the wrong
things and be too controversial that's
okay but what I learned from him and why
he's on the wall here is not being
afraid to express yourself when you have
one idea when you want to do something
when you got that thing inside you that
has to come out a lot of times we hold
it down a lot of times we tell ourselves
all we shouldn't do that people will
judge us Kanye is unafraid Kanye will
not take crap from people in that that
to me is inspiring now I I use that to
turn up if you see in my videos what I'm
at now compared to when I started you'll
notice a lot more passion lot more
energy and that's a variety of factors
but one of them is is having Kanye watch
some videos and seeing how he's unafraid
makes me less afraid to do things and
also the sense of urgency this this
picture is from a radio interview that
he was doing where he was basically
saying that the time is now
I don't want to work inside the
corporation for the next 20 years and
then try to express myself the time is
now to be the greatest you and that
sense of urgency really is inspiring to
me really is motivating to me so that's
why he's up on the wall so quick recap
of everybody here jobs is about having
an impact on the world trying to make a
difference Howard Schultz is about
leading through values and making that
impact through values my parents are
about the value of believe and making
sure that that's what I'm having the
impact on apg Nene's is a role model for
showing me how to make an impact on
believe in betting on the little guy and
Kanye is about not waiting urgency do it
now you're running out of time express
yourself so those are the five on the
wall and then of course my amazing wife
and son Nina and Hayden I look at them
every day and they inspire me to so love
to know what you guys think I'd love to
know what's in your home office the
environment matters if you want to do
great things you can be surrounded by
greatness so share below some of the
things that you have in your office or
you're going to put in your office now
to help you aspire and inspire yourself
to be the best version of you look
forward to seeing comments take care
continue to believe have a great weekend
and and I'll see you soon